i'm gonna clean up because everybody
wants a snoopy nailed him again can i go
now
never mind he's dreaming he's already on
the marine all right let's go back and
take my watch i'm at the point now i'm
wearing up to four different pieces a
day you're a madman i know but i do i
need to be flashy and trashy so i've got
a lot of bling
hey mr wonderful here you know
i always like to challenge teddy on
collecting now the idea here we're in my
one of my favorite i've got to be
careful when i say this one of my
favorite brands in fact my first watch
ever i'm wearing right now
1970s speedmaster this is the moon watch
it's vintage it's beautiful it's got
heritage but we're in the brand right
now and i'm going to flip this coin
because i'm one of us is going to win
heads or tails i'll ask you to choose
teddy and we're going to try to build
the best collection possibly that's four
options to choose from price is no
option nope so whatever draws our eyes
in so who will take from all of these
marvelous watches and create the best
collection well we already know it's
going to be me but we should give teddy
a chance people said that you won last
time i'm i'm kind of mad right now i'm
coming into this with avengers let's go
so i'm going to flip this coin heads or
tails in the air you got to call it
tails
all right let's see
heads
not a good start not a good start that's
absolutely great so i will start
now let's just talk about what is in
inventory here teddy let's go through
you know this brand as well as i do
let's start here so here is our
seamaster collection this is mostly the
diver 300 that you're going to find so
you have traditional seamaster diver 300
which is going to have that healing
escape valve kind of being that pierce
brosnan james bond golden eye watch then
you have more of the heritage models
over here so the sea master 300 which is
going to be from their heritage
collection in the last decade dive
watches have really taken off as part of
men's fashion why do you think that's
happened casual attire people no longer
maybe wearing a suit they just want
something but i've seen people with
tuxes wearing dive watches i think it's
become more of an accepted reality you
look at james bond wearing it and i
think that has become part of the norm
and what people accept as potentially
okay to do what do you think about
what's happened here with omega and
james bond that the brands have merged
in some ways it's so associated now with
omega i mean ever since
95 i mean it's become i would say the
reason why and what we're looking at
right now
almost
the rebirth of what a modern omega is
outside of the speedmaster which has
always been there but this diver 300 has
been the silhouette it's been the watch
that so many people has tried to aspire
to own it's it's defined this type of
collection or what dive wash should be
for that entry-level luxury segment so
given that i won the coin toss i'm going
to choose a piece now from this
collection okay yeah cause i'm thinking
about diver i'm thinking about
chronograph i'm thinking about something
crazy i want to have a good diversified
collection too and i'm really i'm
deciding because you know when you go
dive you go big that's what i'm thinking
so i'm going to go into something that
really pops
right here
chrono yeah semester diver chrono yeah
and the reason i'm choosing this is if
you're going to take a big honk and dial
go all the way go chrono because there's
so much going on in that dial but it's
done beautifully and it's going to look
terrific with a red band on it that's my
thinking so that's number one for me
okay all right okay now let's go on to
this collection this is the planet ocean
yeah do i get to go what are we doing
are we i guess i can let him go maybe
you get to choose am i am i your tour
guide or am i going to smack smash
all right go ahead okay are you going to
stay in this side
should i just you know maybe i should
follow the format maybe i should have i
think i think you're going through
collections trying to pick what really
makes it for you in the portfolio i'm
thinking ahead i've got three more
pieces
so just to give people context of what's
in the case here i do
personally prefer the
seamaster 300 the heritage edition i
knew you were going to say that but are
you going to choose it probably not
because it's only available on the strap
here so i think people might agree with
me on that decision now so you really
want to go metal yeah i think you have
to own it as a dive watch i mean i
certainly certainly could do that but i
have to play the game and pick something
out here i actually really like this
gray dial
blue ceramic bezel i think i'm gonna go
for the seam master divers
300
gray dial so
this is more in my view a fashion piece
it has no heritage linked to it at all
so you're going off piece there teddy
taking a huge risk i might add for the
for the classics and people that really
appreciate this brand you've gone way
off side here i don't think so i think
that is the wash of the last 30 years
except it has a little bit of a
different flair with the dial it's great
i'm not
i'm telling the man himself it says
diversity of violence peace i agree i
agree with that but you this is not the
classic in any way you went you started
classic and you went right off piste
here but i get it i get you've made your
decision you'll have to live with it
let's move on all right pick number two
where are we going you won't you can't
go diver again well i was thinking that
way but you're right i got to get more
diversity
you know they're those are beautiful
pieces
i mean you can do whatever you want yeah
i mean this is really going into fashion
again you know you're doing some crazy
stuff with dials you've got some very
eclectic colors that weren't
traditionally part of what omega was
about all right let's go to speedmaster
now i have to say this is the first
watch i ever bought i'm wearing it a
1975 version of it look at how close to
the heritage they've stayed absolutely
these are interesting but i don't think
i need to select one of these yet
because it's not diverse enough from
what i've got already
all right let's move on oh well dress
watches going for some devilles yeah
some devils
you doing anything here you're it's your
pick i know i'm not there on the dress
watches i think of omega for me as more
of a sports watch brand it's crazy
because of the deville from a
sell-through standpoint and also the
constellation yeah the constellation i
mean those are their four pillars the
ville sea master speedmaster and then
constellation over there which actually
i'm wearing a vintage constellation
right now so i'm a huge fan of the
constellation these are this is really
interesting look at some of these dials
here
okay i'm going to go
right here that is a classic dress piece
really you're surprising me yeah that is
because i have nothing like that that
really stands out that is a fantastic
dress watch would you not agree i agree
i agree there's a little risk in it for
me because when i put a red band on it
it's going to be challenging you're
going gold too you have a lot of bling
going on i know i know but you know i
have moved into wearing some gold
cufflinks occasionally and i have to go
gold for you know i have to build the
portfolio so that's my number two right
there you're gonna have to line these up
against each other we absolutely okay
we'll pull them out at the end and we'll
show everybody are you gonna make a move
here
so as i mentioned
i'm more of a constellation if we're
gonna follow the same format i almost
feel like i need to twist it up also
yeah also but i also did i did line up
some new novel so these are new
novelties for this year so if we do want
to get and have some fun just don't
forget that this exists oh don't yeah i
think you're you're locking into the
cases i don't think you've walked out
you need to start walking around very
interesting you went into the vault i'm
just telling you that's there as well
okay so here we are
these are the constellations these are
gorgeous pieces and some of these are
very eclectic dials by the way they are
see these more like manhattan style like
the griff claw cases like that's really
early 1980s for me yeah i get it and
sort of the solid case like this with
the polish very nice look at this style
here it's off green
that annual calendar flood master yeah
yeah i think i'm gonna go conventional
here yeah conventional glow master my my
simple clean white dial dress watch will
work with everything yeah master
chronometer
all right all right tungsten um
tungsten bezels so that's your second
piece yes you have two more let's go
over here for a moment for my choice
okay because something caught my eye
something caught my eye
you know you know how i love red bands
i know exactly what you're going for i'm
going right here i'll be able to put a
red band on this and this is such a
classic this is your best pick so far
well this is all great picks i don't
know this is the terracotta so this is
the new 38 millimeter uh aqua tear that
they released they updated the bracelet
they rounded out the links and this dial
is actually and you can probably tell
because it uses a different process for
making that dial compared to the rest
and it really allows it to pop and these
are this is an affordable piece this is
6 000 for that so that's a great entry
level piece i mean there's no question
about it omega has really really dialed
it up in entry level pieces it's
brilliant because it gets people into
the brand and then they move up the
feeding chain you know i think by the
way i think women will wear these too
they also launched they launched five
pounds at 38 and five dials at 34. so
you do have these these are the 38 those
are 38 they they work perfectly i mean i
really like how those were is that three
for you you're already three in i know i
know so i have to really be careful on
my next because building a portfolio is
going to blow you away again that's
what's going to happen all right what do
i feel better about where do you want to
go let's let's go back over to sports
okay so sports here all right i have to
pick a speed master at some point you
don't have a speed master in your
collection you have to have one i mean
they are it is the essential omega watch
is it not they came on the scene with
the whole apart you know the whole moon
watch thing boom
every young guy wanted one of these
watches right back to vintage style look
at that now that that's the standard
yeah speed master professional yep
there's two other ones in here and then
i'm also looking at maybe an aquaterra
but i feel that my globemaster prevents
me from going for a conventional aquatic
i agree with you there but if you don't
have a classic i mean come on let me do
the ed white three two one movement yeah
it's a higher price i think around 14
for that but to bring back that movement
plus the case so from a wearability
standpoint this isn't the first omega in
space from a contemporary perspective i
would say it's probably one of the most
wearable speed masters that you can get
and a fantastic contrast on the dial you
can just see it it's almost designed for
being able to just
look to your left if it's on your wrist
and see the time because the contrast is
so strong the black against the white
it's really brilliant same thing here
though but i'm surprised you went in
that direction this is
that that dial is a little more cubic
you know what i mean yes and the
bracelet too just creates a different
type of effect i think for the watch
itself so that's very old school it is
three to one movement no i know that's
really old school so that's terrific um
now you've got three three i'm going to
go to my fourth now as you know there's
a legendary piece that
came onto the scene i have my theory
about why it became so popular but
it's called the snoopy so i'm going back
into speed master land but the snoopy
everyone at first came out people didn't
even get the joke on the back of the
watch there's snoopy on a rocket going
to the moon at the same time
cryptocurrencies were exploding on the
scene this watch came on and what
happened was everybody that talked about
bitcoin going to the moon saw it in this
watch this is my theory about what
happened because when i went to the
first bitcoin conference here so people
were talking about this watch
conversation in this
bitcoin 2020 okay the watch was already
on the market it became the most sought
after watch by kryptonians if you want
to call them that everybody wanted to
have a to the moon watch
you could see them at the conference
those that had one would turn it over
and flip it over and look at this little
ballet playing out with snoopy on a
rocket going around the moon it's an
incredible design idea it's crazy if you
think about it it's so against the
traditional elements of watchmaking you
get a guy to put a dog on a rocket in
the back of the watch it's nuts but it
exploded it was it is one of the most
sought as you know probably and i mean
the silver snoopy award the whole story
goes in the apollo 13 mission when they
were struggling to actually get back to
earth after an explosion and all that
speedmaster was a life-saving
object to have because they were able to
time the engine burns for 14 seconds
that they needed so omega was gifted a
silver snoopy award by nasa and that is
a commemoration of that 50 year
anniversary of that but i think it's
that's such is so important because that
the drama that mission but at the same
time that phrase to the moon is used all
over the world for hopes of people that
buy bitcoin want to see it go to 100
thousand dollars and beyond it's all
classic so this is all you saying that
you're going to get this you're going to
get this i'm basically getting a snoopy
i didn't want you to get it
i decided not to get i was actually a
gentleman in this i let him have so
what's going to happen if i have the
snoopy in the collection we're about to
put on the table here
i'm going to clean up because everybody
wants a snoopy that's basically it
nailed them again it just happens you
get to vote it depends how much people
love the snoopy they might just give you
that just because of the snoopy exactly
where is the snoopy i got to find it
it's over there over here i mean look at
this piece can you imagine the history
of the watch but also everybody that
knows about the snoopy is going to make
me take that off my wrist and show them
the back this is an amazing piece
there's no question about it the best
case back i've seen on a watch we're not
talking about seeing the movement like
what other clothes case back has a cool
this this band is beautiful but i'm
telling you right now teddy not only am
i selecting this into my collection i'm
buying this piece because i'm going to
wear this on shark tank this year i
think so many people want to see this
watch on tv but i'm going to have to put
a red band on it we'll see how mega
feels about that but this piece is going
to be on my wrist on season 14 on shark
tank and you've been wanting this watch
for a long time i have i haven't and
luckily the good people at omega have
made one available to me
i knew that coming in here this is my
watch
see i'm being a gentleman i'm letting
him have what he was right i nailed him
who doesn't want a snoopy are you
kidding i mean this watch is going to be
a major hit major hit and because of the
dial and this this contrast it's going
to look spectacular with a red band on
it don't let him tell you too hard no no
but look don't forget his other picks
i'm going to win this maybe he's
dreaming but this is my first watch in
the 70s isn't that beautiful and the
heritage right through to the snoopy
decades later
this brand knows what it's doing it
keeps the dna dial dial dialed decade
deckhead deckhead it's fantastic
all right can i go now
[Laughter]
listen that was a great contest let's
line up the watches and look at them so
you can get it i have to go oh you have
a boss yeah you haven't got your fourth
never mind he's dreaming he's already on
the marine all right let's let's go back
and take my watch oh i forgot all about
teddy forgot all about him he was in a
trance yeah he was in a trance he was
where we were
going back to sorry
[Applause]
because you you're you're all over this
you've already chosen i can't take a
speed master yeah you can't you're you
know you got to think about what's next
here these guys have done some amazing
things with dials in the last collection
really spectacular oh
i'm doing the world timer oh
see master world time oh you might have
a chance with that
that's got a lot of things happening on
it so at the center you have a grade
five titanium plate that is laser bladed
to look like the world like the globe
i've reviewed the stainless steel one on
my channel this is in full gold so i'm
making a statement here it's 43
millimeters so it's going to be a little
bit larger for my wrist but you kind of
know what you're getting into if you go
all gold so i have to compete with you
it's a little bit of bling for you i got
to tell you but i mean think about how
conventional the rest of my picks were i
had a great dial c master i had a globe
master and then i did
maybe
the epitome of just standard tradition
teddy it's all good and i
encourage you to keep trying but i have
the snoopy and i'm going to clean up you
get to vote but hey i got the snoopy
what do you say let's get the watches in
front of us we'll let you decide
excellent let's line them up okay you
know teddy let's go through our
selections we'll start with me um
remember i'm a dial guy and so what i'm
looking for when i build a portfolio and
a challenge like this where i'm choosing
four pieces i want diversity i want
really unique dials
because when you're you think about
watch collecting you want to go into
your vault and say what am i going to
wear today i'm at the point now i'm
wearing up to four different pieces a
day so i want real diversity i know that
sounds crazy you're a madman i know but
i do i do this so i wear one in the
morning and switch at lunch and then
late afternoon i switch maybe want to go
on my bike ride into a sports piece and
then at night i really want a statement
piece so i tried to reflect that in what
i've done here
this is cl let's just talk dials this is
classic it's beautiful it's such a
statement
about just
watch making i mean this is a heritage
look this is from decades ago but made
in a modern timepiece today with look at
this stunning
i mean this movement in the back is just
look at look at it don't listen to the
sales pitch he's overselling i mean i
got to put sunglasses on this is just
flashing so much it's this is the kind
of thing you do when you're a collector
you build your collection you really
want to have something special this
alone cleans teddy's clock but i've got
more
now remember i said let's go crazy on
dive watch check this out it's a beast
it's a monster it's incredible a dial
like that you can see how different this
is it's just crazy different but part of
the collection is beautiful
now
this isn't even on the market yet and i
spotted it this is the new 2022. this is
going to be a unique piece in my
collection there's no question about it
because it's 38 correct teddy
38 yeah there are 34 millimeter options
available but that is my favorite dial
but it's in my collection so he's just
endorsed my portfolio i'm just a nice
guy i'm gonna say something nice about
mine but but here it comes are you ready
for it are you ready for it are you
ready
for
the snoopy
this watch look at the case look at the
box on the box part of the collection
okay
this is cheating oh come on put it down
there look at this amazing case isn't
that crazy isn't that beautiful
doesn't that say it all
you're basically opening up
into space
it's got a red band on it
oh no
isn't that amazing
i guess this is my watch and it is the
guys at omega made the switcharoo for me
it's red this is going to be such a hit
in shark tank season 14. my goodness now
teddy look
don't be a sore loser but obviously when
you put this into the portfolio
how can you not say this is are you
kidding this is it this is absolutely
the winning portfolio look at how unique
these dials are
remember you want portfolio adversity
and then you've got
snoopy stop the madness
and the back is crazy this this watch is
absolutely nuts
you see snoopy going to the moon on the
back this piece is going to be pulled
off my wrist every day as people see it
they heard about it they want to they're
going to want to see snoopy on the back
now i haven't oversold the portfolio
because it on itself is selling itself
this is an amazing portfolio of omega
just showcases the brand the different
dials the brand new 2022 feature this is
going to be a smoking hot watch i can
tell you where you're going to see it
first on my wrist no question it's gonna
have a red band on it when you see it i
love this piece i love innovation like
this great deals all right i finished
selling
wow
i'm just gonna keep it straight for you
guys don't fall for that all right what
do you got products sell themselves the
salesman doesn't need to work that hard
now first i went with the traditional
seamaster diver 300 meter this is the
gray dial blue ceramic bezel
i like this because they have that wave
dial that looks fantastic to me it's got
that aqua theme with that dial
it does and i like that this is going to
be a gray dial but it still has that pop
with the blue ceramic i think it looks
fantastic now my next piece
was the globe master i'm going very
conventional to start but i like the
globe master i'm wearing a vintage
constellation right now i've always
liked this pie pan look this is just i
think one of the most underrated watches
that omega makes without question it
introduced to their master chronometer
when it was unveiled 8900 moving on the
inside i mean it's killer watch and also
the bezel i just love that i'll give you
i'll give you the first two there is
dial diversity there there's no question
there they are clearly two different you
know versions of of of uh dials i mean
there's nothing similar not with not
even just with color but also texture
yeah and then also with
the protrusions also bands also bands
this is a very very elegant dress band
with the curvature being really i mean
i'm getting some credit now that i look
at it like maybe i should have selected
this one it's really a classic classic
classic
i like the blue one personally but they
didn't have that here so it's so very
nice
okay that's cool all right
i gotta go with the ed white
so i mean this how can i say no to this
it's my first watch i'm wearing the
original
1970s piece right here
you don't have a 321 movement on the
inside no i don't check this out the
heritage is the same though check out
that look at that come on look at that
wow that's crazy you know i got that
sticker there but still i mean look at
that movement that's the original
movement that went to the moon the mania
base lamonia based movement that is used
in the likes from patek philippe
vasheron
and still using the base movement of 321
so it's an icon i mean i have listen
i've always loved this watch for one
there's only one piece in my collection
that was my first watch it's this
because i as a young guy watching the
whole moon drama unfold every guy wanted
one of these omega was so smart to
provide that piece i mean brilliant and
actually kudos to them because many
other brands wanted that that spot but
they were the only one only one's
approved by nasa to actually take on
those missions
and then to
round it all out i had my world timer
that's the crazy piece this is the crazy
piece it is available in steel it's not
available here so i had to go with the
gold which is a little blingy for me but
also this style is spectacular i think
it works i think it works in gold once
in a while you got to bling out you know
as i like to say in miami where i live
here i need to be flashy and trashy so
i've got a lot of bling i got a lot of
lane that's miami you go out at night
you got to be flashy you gotta be trashy
and you want some big statement pieces
from omega you got this you can't go
wrong i don't think this is trap look at
look at that center dial though come on
look look how close it is it is
beautiful it is beautiful see that grade
five titanium plate with the green the
paper it's amazing it's amazing i i mean
it in a nice way when i say flashy i
like to be flashy and it's a world time
so i'm getting diversity in not only
dials complications it's it's good but
unfortunately it doesn't have
the snoopy i was set up there was
something that was done in the
background here where we got a red strap
going on i was set up to lose but you
know what i still think i won i think
the people will speak well we'll see i
mean i think it's fair you should vote
you know obviously i feel very
passionate about omega having in my
first watch it's a great brand but they
have done something incredible over the
decades they keep it fresh and exciting
i mean they bring out new ideas all the
time and you know i look at it this way
if you're collecting and you want
diversity you definitely want omega
because you have diversity and price
point and you have diversity in dial and
you've got style and you go from really
elegant to crazy crazy look at teddy's
crazy these are our two crazy pieces on
the two selections here but
um
you decide you decide but remember
snoopy
i have nothing else to say
i feel cheated that was a lot of fun
teddy thank you good to see you yeah it
was great take care everybody